hey guys i wanted to go back and look at
some more topics regarding game of
thrones
for this video i wanted to make a
detailed path of the downfall of david
and dan's career and some of the red
flags leading up to game of thrones
this will also be a general update as to
what happened to them after the show
like with star wars and their netflix
steel
let's start at the beginning and look at
some of the red flags so for db weiss he
didn't have a lot of experience and the
only notable project he worked on was a
potential film adaption for halo
he was brought in to write the script
but ultimately the project never got off
the ground
so that's not the best time looking at
david benioff he is the one with more
writing experience and has written quite
a few movies
just looking at the blockbuster movies
he has written before game of thrones we
have troy
and x-men origins troy is a pretty mixed
movie according to fans and critics
the main complaint seems to be that the
writing was not good and faithful to the
source material
so david benioff would be to blame for
that and looking at the other movie
x-men origins we have one of the worst
marvel movies
in existence the writing in this movie
was so
terrible that it made marvel fans mauled
from the sheer
dog [ __ ] quality of the script even the
rotten tomato census
wrote david minioff's writing stating
that x-men origin struggles to overcome
a cliche-written script and a familiar
narrative
david benioff was probably the guy who
came up with the idea to sew deadpool's
mouth shut
which is regarded as being one of the
most idiotic writing decisions in film
history so good job benioff so for some
reason this is the prime
candidate to be one of the straw runners
for the biggest tv show in history
by this point it's 2008 and hbo has
already acquired the rights to a song of
ice and fire and has hired benioff
and his friend d.b weiss to short run
the series they probably hired him
because of his quote unquote success
with troy
however since writing original content
seems to be their weakness
they won't have to do that for many
years until they run out of source
material
pepe left season seven and eight oh no
here it comes
so yeah we fast forward to season seven
and eight and this is where things
obviously start to get worse
even with a road map for the story
provided by george rr martin
d seemed to still struggle to pull off
the writing aspect of the show
narrative threads seem to have vanished
like theon greyjoy's manhood
practically all the characters
deteriorated especially in dialogue and
growth
looking at you jon snow and tyrion the
plot armor was thicker than robert
baratheon's waistline
and overall main plot points were not
properly built up to
and executed so it became very clear
that dumb and dumber were not competent
writers without source material
and since they probably realized this
they decided to cut the show down and
just do a couple shortened seasons
even though george r martin and hbo
wanted to do like 13
seasons so in this regard david and dan
did not want to pass on the show
[Music]
you think you can take care of him for
me
psych
and this is where it really starts to
make my blood boil instead of giving the
show its proper life cycle by passing it
on
dumb and dumber acted selfishly and
ended the show as fast as possible to
move on to bigger projects
they did this because this elevates
their status in hollywood as being the
sole creators
of the most popular tv series and they
would end up getting crazy offers from
star wars and netflix
never get another chance like this our
time has finally come
on top of that they took the liberty of
writing almost every episode in season 7
and 8 to try and validate themselves as
being the best and taking more credit
although it was very clear that they
needed help writing the scripts and hbo
even offered to bring in more writers
but d d just wanted it for themselves
and of course this inevitably backfired
hell rang down from the community as
everyone realized how bad the writing
actually was
so many questions man seriously ain't
supposed to die like that
what i mean there's so many questions it
was so bad
that 1.8 million fans signed a petition
to remake season 8 with competent
writers
i will not only sign a petition i would
put my face
on the front of the dagger daggone
pamphlet that y'all taking around the
backlash got even worse to the point
that d d
canceled their scheduled appearance at
comic con in 2019
freaking cowards man i know we're
following the game of thrones panel
which is a [ __ ] nightmare just
objectively
um i also know that their showrunners
didn't show up because they didn't want
to answer questions about the show
after a couple months they went to the
austin film festival
and there they talked more about their
time at game of thrones and the main
revelation was that dnd heavily
downplayed the fantasy element of the
show
you know we tried to keep that stuff to
a minimum because
we didn't just want it to appeal to
a fantasy fan base we wanted them to
love it and we wanted
parents to love it and people who played
professional football to love it
and they never really sat down to try
and boil down
all the books essential elements as they
found the scope to be too
big and to me this is one of the most
annoying revelations
dumb and dumber actively cut down and
oversimplified the show to make things
easier a prime example of this is bran
in season six we find out that he can
interact with the past and can warg into
anything
but what do they do with this in season
8 nothing he just wargs into some crows
so by decreasing the scope and fantasy
elements of the show
dumb and dumber tried to simplify the
writing to make their jobs easier
and by doing so they ruined the final
seasons of game of thrones
[Music]
[Laughter]
towards the end of the run in 2017 dumb
and dumber were pitching their original
series hbo called confederate
the premise is that the civil war ended
in a stalemate and slavery is still
around
that terrible premise is pretty much the
equivalent of a third grader asking a
what-if question to their history
teacher
these two knuckleheads thought it would
make for a good tv drama if we lived in
an alternate universe where slaves were
still around
yikes obviously hbo did not want to
produce the show
and david and dan received a lot of
backlash on twitter for it
people said that it was basically slave
fan fiction and that it just sounded
like a terrible idea
after this whole series pitch they were
approached to do a trilogy for star wars
in february 2018.
this is also where things kind of get
depressing because disney was probably
in talks with dumb and dumber before
2018
and this whole development probably led
them to the decision to rush game of
thrones to its end
especially since they've been expressing
that they've been worn out by the show
it's very hard to work on something for
364 and a half days a year for 10 years
without feeling like it's your own
so for the star wars deal they were
supposed to come up with an original
trilogy
which to be honest at this point i
wanted to see how bad it was going to be
but it didn't end up coming to fruition
overall
there is not much detail as to what
happened besides dnt backing out the
star wars deal
and taking a 200 million dollar contract
with netflix
through the timeline of the end of game
of thrones and the netflix deal
dumb and dumber had about a year to
pitch and write a trilogy for star wars
a whole year so this makes you think
that they utterly failed to come up with
a good script or idea
it's also funny because in game of
thrones they complained about the scope
of the series being too big
but star wars also has a massive scope
with tons of lore
and rules to follow within its universe
that and it didn't seem like they were
taking this dream job opportunity very
seriously given that david benioff had
the main writing credit in gemini man
and surprise surprise the main complaint
about the movie was
the writing so while these degenerates
were struggling to come up with a
trilogy for star wars
they took the easy way out and ditched
their contract with disney and took a
multi-year film
and tv deal with netflix and you'd have
to be pretty bad at writing to pass up
on an opportunity to write movies for
star wars
so going into the netflix deal this is
where things get even more interesting
about their downfall
it's been a whole year now that david
and dan have been working at netflix
and what have they done they directed
one comedy special with leslie jones in
january 2020
which to me is hilarious the top shore
runners in hollywood go from game of
thrones
to a leslie jones comedy special oh
my god
[Applause]
it seems like netflix at the time had no
idea what to do with dumb and dumber
probably because they were pitching
terrible ideas for shows and movies on
the level of confederate
although this is mostly speculation but
like what else have they been doing at
netflix for the past year
they could have been doing nothing else
besides pitching shows and movies to
netflix
and they have probably been denying all
of them because of how bad the writing
is
why do you think i came all this way
so until recently we found out that
david and dan along with alexander wu
will be the showrunners for a new series
that will be a book adaption for the
three body problem
which this whole scenario is pretty
ironic because d d ended up getting
thrown back into a book adaption
when they had the opportunity to do
whatever they wanted
i think netflix finally realized what
these two buffoons are good at
making book adaptions but yeah this is
basically where david and dan are at
currently
they just now announced this new series
and it's probably just starting
pre-production
it's just crazy how these two guys go
from being the top creators in hollywood
to then getting the opportunity to do a
star wars trilogy
and then ending up doing nothing for
netflix for a whole year
i'm sure netflix at this point is
regarding making a 200 million
deal with these two morons and now dumb
and dumber are back to making adaptions
you